pivot and see because he's had a lot of
these missed opportunities yeah I I
invited him to go to the Philippines
with me in March and now he's insisting
that he fly first class because not for
any other reason then he thinks he will
run into some type of [ __ ] cheek or
something and that's gonna give him some
type of like makeup for like a missed
opportunity in the past he thinks he's
gonna run into important people in the
first class what do you think they're
gonna do for you I want to tell you a
story friend it works all the time
well you could just say I want to find
first class because I want to be in
first class
yeah but the first class tickets 12,000
dollars you can afford it right I will
not we are young I won't do it and I'm
doing it as more of a joke like who what
what idiot is gonna spend twelve
thousand dollars on a plane ticket why
is it that much all the way to there
that's a cheap end that's a cheap end
you should do it and I go I'll just do
one weekend and like the wise guys and
I'll do you know yeah or or boo fly
what's the name of the airline
Philippine area narrow I am why don't
you tweet a Korean air and go listen is
a person I'll cross a tag robe knowing
the overheads are fret yeah I imagine if
you tweet at them
what is this trend of all these comics
tweeting out Airlines by the way do you
notice this thing oh my god it's all
over the internet it's all over Twitter
you lose yours who's my wife who do you
tweet no no no I don't i see comics Adam
Devine Chris D'Elia all these guys they
talk [ __ ] to the airline they're like
you [ __ ] up my [ __ ] nutter and
airlines always go hey please DM us
we'll take care of it because I don't
wanna get their spot blown out all right
they take care of customer service stuff
all that you tweet like crazy to Korean
air and be like listen but keep tweeting
every day have one of these guys [ __ ]
do it keep tweeting every day just start
tonight hi hi into the find a gif of you
yeah right and then say hi just a little
Bobby yeah yeah
on the street with my friend uh-huh give
every day until finally be like listen
I'm I'm trying to take this this trip to
take my girlfriend back to but what if
only he gets the first-class ticket and
I'm all the way in [ __ ] code no I
told you lady that I will get you
business business is not college
business is not code if I have a little
private room right after my slumber I'll
go out and if I have like a muffin or
something that they gave me I'll slide
it your way they don't let you interact
with with it is painfully economical so
yesterday on our flight back from DC he
had first class and I was in coach what
yeah you will fly first class I will not
spend an extra 1,300 1,300 dollars for
me I'm perfectly comfortable you're
there but you're more perfectly
comfortable in first class I'm
uncomfortable thinking that 1,300
dollars is spent on my behalf I'd rather
that go somewhere else
but we're like groceries but the animal
bills so you're gonna get though you're
gonna buy that stuff anyway I don't know
I just don't feel good about it I know
but I got over this hump to I used to
feel bad I used to feel bad about stuff
okay well first class it is to the
Philippines thank you not business no
not for you for me I get first class you
get business okay I'll take business
yeah that's still a lot of money
yeah no I'm yeah I don't know what
Korean air does economy whatever they
serve you in first class trip to eat raw
fish they serve Korean food or
Philippines they have they have you have
a flight right there how much $2,000
flight if it's because of what is
Filipino food delicious is what it's
it's duck embryos we have a dough ball
dobos Mexicali right you know what dude
well it's Spanish for people to come to
my shows I'm just when I say things like
that you don't have to worry about
Filipinos gonna say that this weekend of
Filipino guy goes he'd raise his hand is
I know I'm a jungle Asian and I he said
that out loud oh yeah yeah yeah and I
cuz I say that all I know I do a lot and
then look at him and I want no dude I
was just a joke I love you you know me
but in my head I'm like why do I say
stuff like that alright and I want to
never listen here's it here's the deal
but Bobby
wants to grow Bobby Lee wants to connect
so you know the two kids that came
they're not black kids they're just
regular people right they were black you
said that yeah I know I should have said
that the wimpy no way you said it to his
on tape it's on tape I know and I
apologize you want a you went like this
they were like but you know what you're
I I want to get over that I'm 47 years
old and I need to grow
[Music]